something strange is going on and it's
strange even for Donald Trump's
standards he is now regularly posting
and reposting messages to truth social
in the middle of the night truth
essential forget about the fact that he
sometimes doesn't even know what his own
platform is called forget about that for
a second
um this really might be the end of trump
but I want to be very careful about
prematurely reporting the death of one's
political career they can come back
there were people in 2016 who said Trump
has no chance and of course they were
wrong even recently even close to the
2016 election day I thought Trump had no
path to Victory so let's be careful
about declaring his political career
dead but Donald Trump does seem very
damaged at this point in time he's being
kept out of the Georgia a senate race
Herschel Walkers race in Georgia
and he is now regularly posting nonsense
to truth social all night long check out
this really strange stuff on Tuesday
around 10 30 a.m Donald Trump posted in
all caps remember you can never have
fair and free elections with mail-in
ballots never never never won't and
can't happen and then at 2 13 in the
morning early this morning Donald Trump
re-trothed it adding also in all caps
one more never
Trump also posting at 12 15 a.m this
morning this election cycle reminds me
so much of 2016. much more so than 2020
where I actually did much better got 12
million more votes Fox News and the Wall
Street Journal the wall Journal were
terrible to me to me much like today
until I won the election CNN when they
actually had great ratings was terrific
they covered me no matter where I went
24 7. the big difference is my record
best economy and Border no inflation or
Wars energy Independence record jobs
strong military worldwide respect and so
much more
and then dozens just dozens of other
retroths a retroth is sort of like a
retweet because truth Central just
copied Twitter but as you page down it's
just video posts and retroths and just
endless endless endless posting dozens
and dozens and dozens of time uh he also
went after Karl Rove in one of his rants
posting quote Rhino Carl Rove a man with
a losing record the likes of which few
political operatives would be able to
get away with including his loss to me
in 2016. fight so hard and so stupidly
but is constantly on Fox News and the
once Great Wall Street Journal
explaining how things should be done and
he doesn't have a clue people can't
stand him a clone of even more unpopular
Paul Ryan who sadly runs Fox News Now on
a very bad path Rove is a denier of
deniers but it's completely misspelled
d-i-n-i-e-r am I missing something about
what Trump is doing here misspelled
denier of deniers which makes him a fool
watch so the important question
is whether Trump is actually weakened is
Trump actually weakened right now well
what do the betting markets say and what
do the latest polls say if we start with
the betting markets indeed Ron DeSantis
has as strong of a position in the 2024
Republican primary as he has ever had
Donald Trump is still in a very
respectable second place now the numbers
need a little bit of interpretation if
you had a situation here where Ron
DeSantis and Donald Trump had never been
president
and had either both or both or neither
had announced that they were running in
2024 and you saw these numbers you might
say okay I mean it's still very early
neither has announced and neither has
been president 40 32 okay it's kind of
not not hugely meaningful
the difference is Ron DeSantis in the
betting markets is now healthfully ahead
of Donald Trump Ron DeSantis hasn't
announced that he's running for anything
and Donald Trump has already been
president of the United States and yet
you see these numbers that is quite
interesting we then can look at actual
polling and we're only looking at this
like every couple weeks it's it's not
really a horse race yet but it is
interesting to see that the polling is
quite split right now a new yougov poll
has Trump up six over DeSantis but
notice it's only 36 to 30 and when you
look at more data you see that Don Jr is
pulling nine percent in that poll
imagine that Mike Pence is pulling eight
percent
Etc Trump plus six there's another poll
from communication Concepts which
already has DeSantis plus five 45 to 40.
and then as you read down the line you
see that there are polls in which Donald
Trump is leading and polls in which
Rhonda santis is leaving but importantly
it is so early in this thing and Trump
has already been president and Ron
DeSantis hasn't even announced that it
is quite stunning to a degree to see
Donald Trump polling this poorly Trump
was polling poorly at the beginning of
the 2016 Republican primary and so we're
making no conclusions but his
increasingly erratic Behavior being kept
out of Georgia when it comes to Herschel
Walker and both the polling and betting
Market data not looking particularly
good 2024 could be a very different
Republican primary and a contested
Republican primary against a former
Republican president that is a very
different situation and quite unique
we're going to follow it I love reading
I read every day no matter how I arrange
my schedule I never have enough time to
read all the books that I want which is
why blinkist has been such an important
part of my life for years now our
sponsor blinkist is the app that takes
thousands of non-fiction books boils
them down into an explainer that you can
read or listen to in just 15 minutes
which includes all the most important
takeaways from the book with blinkist I
can absorb the essence of 15 different
books in an afternoon so I can quickly
gather insights from all sorts of
perspectives make connections have those
kind of aha moments that don't happen so
easily which is why I feel enriched when
I use blinkist blinkist also summarizes
episodes of popular podcasts into
15-minute explainers and with the
blinkist connect feature my girlfriend
and I can share one account share books
podcasts with each other talk about them
on the go and don't forget blinkist
makes the perfect holiday gift my
audience can try blinkist free for seven
days and get 25 off after that go to
blinkist.com Pacman the link is is down
below